hey guys we're here with the official
dr. fate character breakdown from nether
realm now this did come from a developer
livestream so if you see something weird
remember that it's a work in progress
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
all the latest injustice to character
reveals and breakdowns his sweep they
all use magic effects he doesn't
actually like touch it right he almost
he has almost no physical attacks his
jump attacks are all magic base which is
a really cool touch and even as dash is
a teleport yeah so nobody else yeah it's
not very very unique he's gonna is he a
boulder bouldering that - he is not it
functions like a - but it's just a
really cool visual touch for almost all
of his moves like his okay thanks Derek
alright there's one thing about playing
this game of Derek's in the room he has
a controller yeah don't forget what
we're doing or trying to do and be like
I gotta push a button that's me I wish
but he's just a childlike hype tool yeah
yeah thank you
i wad you want to say that we were
giving the comics out and everybody
gonna wanted us to the street challenge
blowing by well it's good stuff good
stuff cuz people having fun I'm excited
about so I got to join words about this
actually - it's like one of his new
design ideas well you really wanted a
lot of magic to be bright like Oh most
of the ways he moves and interactions or
magic yeah and it really comes through
it's a really cool effect um like his 1
1 3 ends in kind of a projectile attack
and you can actually charge it or you
can even cancel it
and then go a new pressure or guessing
just 1 1 2 is this big pillar of fire oh
do the 2 1 1 1 2 3 yeah this is my
favorite because zap that's a really
good combo under love it and his back
one down three up three actually ends in
a stomp with the man but it's a magical
stop
that's a magical stop stop brought to
you by magic
No yeah cuz back to is a really good
anti-air that's again he's not making
contact it's a killer even as for three
of those batteries our magical confused
back threes and four three your magic
pure magic
okay moving along so his special moves
are where he really shines he has some
of the best long-distance special moves
his fireball is very very quick I like
to call that a few the pewte yeah you I
do that while playing Yuki
it has a very fast recovery it's very
hard for people to deal with and the
meet over one actually shoots three
that's the debut that's too pewpew right
so the idea is the opponent's trying to
get in and if you think they're going to
commit to dashing or jumping you go with
the three and they'll take a lot of
damage so would you say like of the
character we've shown he's kind of the
first trees owner or he's what I would
call a hard summer that that is his
that's what he does okay so his second
projectile is a displacer or which is a
slower-moving bigger or that he can then
follow behind it or do his other
projectiles upon you can do the three
one and that will come on force the
opponent to take action or you can
actually as a bar meter and stop it in
place at any time
so we can stop it really close and then
hide behind it or you could stop it
right in front of the opponent or he
could not stop it at all and the
opponent has to kind of guess which
version of this projectile he's going to
do I feel around the chatter saying that
they really like the look of face magic
yeah in my opinion he has some of the
coolest effects in the game it looks it
looks great and what effects team yeah
yeah yeah big shut-eye do you want to
say I hope to have some of the effects
team on at some point because just a
quick sub them just going to break off
real quickly you know the characters of
the characters you guys designed them
and you make them fight one of the
things that really gives them their
personality is the effects team like it
really make they make what you guys do
sing just like I mean really everybody
in the building yes apps does that but
we do the effects team are a very big
part of how the game looks we're hoping
to have some of the moms tune to talk
about stuff and there's absolutely
gorgeous effects and I love the details
in the animation that have a personality
come out like just look at his back walk
how he actually moves while he's back
walking doing little magical we talked
to Nick about how the fact that like the
thing that makes the characters so much
fun and injustice to is that they play
well they're fun to play but they're so
deeply like mayors and everything is
yeah it flows through so um that just is
normal 3 right yeah that's just a
standing three really cool his heart
attack is literally not he does nothing
physical at all so um in addition to his
two projectiles he has this little
healing aura he can put on screen and
then when he's in it he is healing you
can actually see the effect of it adding
to him and you can do it behind so you
can put it behind you while you're doing
your zoning in the opponent they have to
get you even if dr. fate doesn't have
the life lead he can regain the life
lead by healing while he's standing that
doesn't just heal him right
not just Yeltsin I thought take the
knock penguin here I don't think so
Thanks time way to go but we will get to
something else that can do and maybe I
come down you will get oh yeah yeah I
was absentia long so anyway and then
then he does have an up-close special
move which even though it's an A+
special move it plays into his defensive
play style so he has this glitch where
he actually shoots it back and this will
knock the opponent far away and this is
safe on block and it has pushed back on
what can you block for a second yeah
just hold down yeah so you can see dr.
fate will be pushed back so this would
be the move you use up close like can
you block for a second yeah I guess yeah
so even when you're up close with dr.
fate and you want to create space this
would be a great move to use and the
beat everyone goes back you can further
now you get it and you can see they get
pushed way back so this is coming your
all-purpose you're up close and you're
panicking and you want to close you want
to make that gap again this is I'm going
to use the glyph well and that's also
like one of his main Punishers ah when
you punish an unsafe attack cool then he
has um ng the down back freeze yeah
let's do the down back threes he has
these long secant something and he
summons it and then it will float around
you it'll never go away and then at any
point you can get down for three it'll
summon it on the opponent that's an
unblockable it'll attach to them and do
just a little bit of damage and you can
do three of them
so you're free to do it as you want you
can do one and then go throw some
fireballs or Joey yeah then eventually
when the elbow three you can summon all
three they'll all attached and then a
pillar will go up that's awesome and
then that will launch the opponent now
do those track they do it will go to
where the opponent is very searched
there's there's a meta game with inside
playing who I'm trying to give them all
of it right it's you know obviously -
that one - not gonna fail
yeah you have to you have to get the
opponent standing so that all three will
come down they won't just home but they
will track on where you were before you
start moving right and if you don't get
hit by all three the pillar the Miller
and the pillar is only the bonus for
hitting all three so like Tyler said the
metagame here is taking the time like
maybe you and your combo and then you
get a pillar out and then later you
could do something you get to pull
around and all right not a pillar a
knockout and then we give all three
that's when you try to freeze them up
maybe freeze this or and then you get
all three and then you're gonna get your
combo what you didn't do which I didn't
do well I want to see some sweet
combinations I'll get to that
whoa I'll get to that so quickly talk
about that real quick combination
combinations it's a new thing I was
trying to create new terminology yes I'm
gonna combos Corner columns in front of
mine what's on TV
you got a TV that's elastic the new one
is combinations so with it now be corner
combination so far cup stuff okay so
when you're doing combos now Golconda
Oh continue uh yeah in a wall-like huh
no okay corner comes kind of cat kinda
kind again so his final special move is
my favorite Sheridan's lock which is a
magic spell he uses which actually locks
out level interactions for the opponent
you can see that hunk in front of the
background bounce there here you see
this a little tablet that is no wat and
Derek cannot use my can I use it but dr.
fate still can this is one of my
favorite parts of the time yeah it's so
cool
the design team work it was really smart
kind of put a little outside the box
with some of this stuff like kind of
going into a magical realm you know like
that's not something he does to someone
else but he's affecting the environment
if you want to talk about how you space
control right not only does he do with
his damage he does it by not allowing
the opponent to use things to help them
control space yes it's really really
really creative so his character power
is dark magic you and see the bar at the
end and that shows that it's available
and then you turn it on
he turns red and it begins to countdown
and this is a buff to all of his special
moves his fireballs are not red and they
do significantly more damage his orb and
now his orb does significant more damage
and then it does bigger reactions for
other moves for example it's down back
to well now push you back instead of
just a little bit of push you back
fullscreen and the meter bird one this
is the big deal it's a full-on combo
slots
this look at there's magic uh uh magical
so you asked earlier for combos and this
is really the key was calm what I asked
come a combination sorry normally dr.
fate isn't really a combination
character he doesn't even appear right
he's more of a keep away character once
he has this out the X down back to
becomes prime compost are um his healing
thing actually turns into a damaging or
and if the opponent gets in that they
are damaged their health will start to
drink there goes and you can again set
it behind you if you think the opponent
would maybe teleport behind you or you
can set it in front of them and now it's
a shield at the opponent you know they
can no longer just walk through right
another changes it does it actually
changes up struck his throw has a
different follow-up at the end and in
the corner he gets a combination that's
catching on it yeah and tonight
let's see another of catching out
hitting on one person case throw will do
a lot more damage and then it'll bounce
up
all right can I say how much crap I get
for dropping combos and this guy over
here this drama - left and right he also
does combos you take the few times we
take each yeah I mean my track records
like 5050 yours is like never never I've
even said that Tyler hi that is me no
that's fine that's fine um it also
affects aunts the three aunts behaved
the same he can get three of them except
they will become traps on the floor that
hit individually and you can do this
they don't have to hit the opponent
they'll go on the ground and then
they'll explode individually and the
cool thing is if he has two aunts out or
one on if you turn your trade on they
still turn on and turn red and turn to
dark magic awesome um alright and you
want to show remove for fun yeah
to me the idea the base idea here would
be when you don't have trade on your
pure defense you want to stay as far as
way as possible like trade makes
everything more aggressive he gets his
combo starter because it's damaged
cursed these become offensive dogs
become offensive so he's all about when
you need to make a comeback or when you
want to extend your life lead that's
when you turn the trade on and then you
have your ten seconds or however long it
is - he's even more powerful to go ham
as the children's to go ham so super
move even assuming which is far reaching
nothing is enough here
yeah go there's lots of little dr. Bates
a lot of doctor fates right all right
all doctors all doctors yeah PhDs let us
move in to go to his second all right
second load second load out yes so for
this one let me see what I wrote down on
the old paper here we go
okay so this one we got obviously a
sweet new outfit
yes dear set four we've got some kinds
of bronze looking going on some purple
so with this one we gave given him the
secret form
oh this is good so the thing about
doctor fate is a lot of his abilities
modify or someone alter or improve a lot
of his magical attacks rather than like
totally replace them yeah for example
his orb is slower moving but it will not
actually homed in on the opponent he can
delay if he wants to release it when he
wants to release it or can just do it
and it'll actually track him if he's
jumping down and you can see that it's
slower moving so you can actually just
go in and actually meet it like he can
reach the opponent for the orb does that
allows for all kind of sounds hey if you
can do Tyler know roasted know yeah burn
will Derek's also jumping around yeah
that's what I do yeah and I don't care
okay
um is there a way you meet agreed we
must go get also stop it
and then and then the second one is I
didn't write it down right now she did
not write up its that yes it's the nope
do the back do that do the honks its
nope okay nope nope nope nope nope no no
no there it is oh I don't
this changes his healing and his curse
move and it makes it so that it will act
be active if he goes into it so let's
say you have a healing or arm out if you
go into it it'll explode and immediately
just give it out then and the opposite
is true of the dark one you can have it
out there and if the opponent goes in
and immediately explode right so this
makes it even more dangerous as a shield
so you can have it out and the opponent
really has to be careful and then you
could couple that with the orb
so the opponents afraid to get in I am
terrified yeah and then you start doing
your orb and you've really filled a
screen with your rings with your tree
like this I would have gone with magical
stuff magical spells okay I trinkets
rydym yeah yeah okay let's move on to
the next loadout so that would
definitely be an example of a loadout to
just continue what he's already good at
which is keep out so what would happen
in a matchup where dr. fate get stoned
out himself another powerful zoner
likes a dead shot or a mere myths or
perhaps a hair match which you don't
like I don't like your majesty
absorption spell turns his cliff into a
projectile absorbed you will actually
absorb it
I'm it Steve I got it the first time
Mary all right look at that
yeah and it's a very it's pretty easy
viewer reaction it covers up a lot of
the screen it's very fast I like how the
little projectile just guess my mouse so
this would be a good one to use like I
said again someone else who also is a
good zone so dr. fate will always have
the zoning advantage check tiles are
meetings and then what if it was a
matchup where dr. fate needs to get in
he has increased mobility with air -
another gear
yes gear ability you go off so normally
he's not a character that wants to get
in close and he has kind of some trouble
getting in close so if you're having
that you can use this one and it's a lot
easier to close the gap and once you've
controlled the ground with your
projectiles that we talked about you can
then use it to control the air with your
- oh yeah let's let's let's get back to
get back to the boys here say thank you
Steve thanks Dee very much for talking
about dr. fate yeah he's a really cool
character just